This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When producer Chris Baroubaix was growing up, he spent a lot of time with his grandparents in a suburb just outside of Montreal. I loved those visits, but coming from English Canada, I couldn't help but notice all the subtle differences when I was in Quebec. Like how all the gas stations had this winking, tired owl logo on the outside, or how the Simpsons all spoke
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当制作人克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroubaix）长大的时候，他花了很多时间在蒙特利尔郊外的一个小镇上陪他的祖父母。我喜欢那些拜访，但作为一个英语加拿大人，当我身处魁北克时，我不禁注意到所有微妙的区别。比如所有的加油站外面都有这个眨着眼睛、面露倦容的猫头鹰标志，或者《辛普森一家》里的人怎么都说
with working-class Montreal French accents. Ah, we saw sit-in-reboot. No, oh, keep up the rest. But this one thing really got to me. Every morning, I would sit down for breakfast and I'd get my toast toast and I would look in the butter dish. And there would be margarine, right?
着工人阶级的蒙特利尔法式口音。啊，我们看过情景喜剧重启版。不，噢，跟上其余的部分。但有一件事真的很让我纠结。每天早上，我都会坐下来吃早饭，拿到我的烤面包，然后我会看看黄油碟。里面会有植物黄油，对吧？
Okay, that's not so weird. Lots of people like margarine, but let me explain. Margarine is this spread made with vegetable oil that's supposed to closely mimic butter. Pass the butter, please, Vicki. Vicki, the butter. Hey, what's going on? I switched from butter to imperial margarine. You mean this is margarine? But there was something off about my grandparents' margarine.
好吧，这并不那么奇怪。很多人喜欢植物黄油，但让我解释一下。植物黄油是用植物油制成的一种抹酱，旨在高度模仿黄油。请把黄油递给我，维姬。维姬，黄油。嘿，怎么回事？我从黄油换成了帝国牌植物黄油。你的意思是这是植物黄油？但我祖父母的植物黄油有点不对劲。
It didn't look like butter. In fact, it kind of looked like lard. The reason for this was a Quebec law that prohibited yellow margarine. For years in Quebec, the full butter spread wasn't a soft, buttery color. Instead, it was a pale, grayish, white. And as a kid, I just didn't get it. Why would anyone make a law about the color of margarine? Who cares? At the time, I wrote it off as just another specific Quebec thing. But it turns out the law in Quebec was just one small battle in a global 150-year war to destroy Marjorin and everything that it stands for. And in its fight for survival,
它看起来不像黄油。事实上，它看起来有点像猪油。原因是一项禁止黄色植物黄油的魁北克法律。在魁北克的多年里，这种满铺的黄油抹酱并不是柔软的黄油色。相反，它是苍白的、灰白色的。作为一个孩子，我就是不明白。为什么会有人为植物黄油的颜色制定法律？谁在乎呢？当时，我把它归结为又一个魁北克特有的现象。但事实证明，魁北克的法律只是全球长达150年、旨在消灭植物黄油及其代表的一切的战争中的一场小型战役。为了生存，
Marjorin has had to reinvent itself over and over again. Our relationship with food is always changing. Like, I have no idea if we think eggs are good or bad at this point. But the story of Marjorin is particularly turbulent. Marjorin has been this bellweather for different food trends and fads in our diet culture. The fickle public has gone back and forth on Marjorin so many times, it feels like whiplash. The story of Marjorin, this boring spread, is an epic saga, with four dramatic chapters.
植物黄油不得不一次又一次地重塑自己。我们与食物的关系总是在变。比如，我现在根本不知道我们究竟觉得鸡蛋是好是坏。但植物黄油的故事格外波折。植物黄油一直是我们饮食文化中各种食物潮流和风尚的风向标。反复无常的公众对植物黄油的态度变来变去，让人感到晕头转向。植物黄油的故事——这个无聊的抹酱——是一部史诗般的传奇，有着四个戏剧性的篇章。
Chapter 1. A miracle of science The reason we have Marjorin is because of the French emperor Napoleon Bonaparte III. I mean, of course, right? You probably could have guessed that. In the 1860s France was heading towards a war with Prussia, and Napoleon III had to find a cheap way to feed the entire French navy. Napoleon III put out a call for an invention of a spread that could replace butter that was portable for his troops and also cheaper to produce. This is Food Historian
第一章：科学的奇迹。我们之所以有植物黄油，是因为法国皇帝拿破仑三世。我的意思是，理所当然，对吧？你可能已经猜到了。在19世纪60年代，法国正走向与普鲁士的战争，拿破仑三世必须找到一种便宜的方法来养活整个法国海军。拿破仑三世发出了征集令，要求发明一种可以替代黄油的抹酱，既方便他的军队携带，又更便宜。这是食物历史学家
Elaine Costa Rova. And I am the author of Butter a Rich History. A terrific name for books. Seemed obvious. Napoleon III set up a contest with a cash prize to whoever could make the best fake butter. The standout was from a French chemist named Hippolyt's Mégé Marie, called Oliomargerin. Later they just brought the Oliopart. And this one particular chemist came up with this mixture of beef call fat, so this kind of excess beef fat that's trimmed off, which he reduced to an oil and then mixed with milk and salt. Yeah, the process does not sound great, but it tasted pretty good. Apparently it was quite palatable.
伊莱恩·科斯塔·罗娃（Elaine Costa Rova）。我是《黄油：一段丰富的历史》一书的作者。一个极好的书名。看起来很显而易见。拿破仑三世设立了一场比赛，为制作出最好的人造黄油的人提供现金奖。最突出的是一位名叫伊波利特·梅日-穆里е（Hippolyte Mégé-Mouriès）的法国化学家，名为“油质人造黄油”（Oliomargerin）。后来他们简称其为“Olio”。这位特定的化学家想出了这样一种混合物：牛脂，也就是被切掉的这种多余的牛肉脂肪，他将其提炼成油，然后与牛奶和盐混合。是的，这个过程听起来不太好，但味道相当不错。显然它相当可口。
I've been tempted a couple of times to try to reproduce it just to know what it tasted like, but so far I've not done that. So actually the very first margarine, certainly an animal product, not anything like the margarines we have today, or have had, you know, for the last 100 years. Margarine had a lot going for it. It was cheaper than butter. It kind of sorted tasted like butter, and it was perfect for the navy because it could be taken on long sea voyages and it wouldn't go rancid. But the French really loved their butter. So at first, Margren did not take off.
我有几次想尝试复制它，只是为了知道它是什么味道，但到目前为止我还没有这样做。所以实际上最初的人造黄油绝对是一种动物产品，一点也不像我们今天拥有的人造黄油，或者说过去100年里有过的那些。人造黄油有很多优点。它比黄油便宜；它的味道有点像黄油；而且它非常适合海军，因为它可以在漫长的海上航行中携带而且不会变质。但法国人真的很爱他们的黄油。所以一开始，植物黄油并没有流行起来。
Mesdmari sold his patent in the 1870s, and this could have been it for Margren. It could have become one of those thousands of food products that roll out with lots of hype and then disappear, like Crystal Pepsi or Doritos Wow. But Marjorant found a ready market across the ocean in America. Under the guidance of the deceptively named United States Dairy Company, Marjorant was introduced to Americans. And shoppers were excited.
梅日-穆里埃在19世纪70年代卖掉了他的专利，这本可以成为植物黄油的结局。它本可以成为成千上万种大肆宣传随后又消失的食品之一，比如水晶百事可乐或多力多滋惊奇味（Doritos Wow）。但植物黄油在大洋彼岸的美国找到了现成的市场。在听起来极具欺骗性的美国乳业公司（United States Dairy Company）的指导下，植物黄油被介绍给美国人。购物者们很兴奋。
Because around this time, butter was expensive, and if you didn't have money your alternative was buying rancid butter or another product called renovated butter which was really gross. Renovated butter was essentially butter that had gone bad or cream it didn't really churn correctly and they would so-called renovate it, they would process it, you know, adding more salt, some oils, you know, they would just basically put in whatever they could to make it cohesive and spreadable with little regard for taste.
因为大约在这个时候，黄油很贵，如果你没有钱，你的选择就是买变质的黄油或另一种叫做翻新黄油的产品，这真的很恶心。翻新黄油本质上是变质的黄油或搅拌不成功的奶油，他们会所谓地“翻新”它，对其进行加工，你知道的，加入更多的盐、一些油，你知道的，他们基本上会投入任何能让它具有凝聚力和可涂抹性的东西，而对味道却不太讲究。
I mean, it was generally really nasty stuff. Given the truly disgusting alternatives, shoppers flocked to Margarine. By 1882, New York State was producing over 20 million pounds a year. So, rich people got to enjoy their creamy non-ransed butter and the rest of us got slightly less creamy but still non-ransed
我的意思，它通常真的很恶心。鉴于这些真正令人作呕的替代品，购物者蜂拥购买植物黄油。到1882年，纽约州一年的产量超过2000万磅。所以，有钱人可以享受他们的奶油味非变质黄油，而我们其他人则得到了稍微没那么奶油味但仍然非变质的
margarine and everybody was happy. Everybody except for dairy farmers. They panicked. Dairy farmers were like, wait a second, you're producing a cheaper alternative to what we're selling that looks exactly the same as what we're selling and to at least to some pallets is indistinguishable. This is Christopher Burns. I'm an archivist at the Silver Special Collections Library at the University of Vermont and a Butter Historian. Yes, for those keeping track, I found two Butter Historians.
植物黄油，每个人都很高兴。每个人，除了奶农。他们惊慌失措。奶农们觉得，等一下，你们生产了一种比我们卖的东西更便宜的替代品，看起来和我们卖的东西一模一样，而且至少对某些人的味蕾来说是无法区分的。这是克里斯托弗·伯恩斯（Christopher Burns）。我是佛蒙特大学银色特藏图书馆的档案管理员，也是一位黄油历史学家。是的，对于那些在做记录的人，我找到了两位黄油历史学家。
Yeah, I know how to do this job. The Butter Lobby felt threatened by Martin. They weren't about to stand by and watch this upstart become the new popular bread spread. Big Butter had to fight back. Chopped or two, a public enemy. In the 1880s, the dairy lobby helped spread rumors in Innuwendo about the looming threat of Margarine. The start of this campaign of disinformation about Margarine
是的，我知道怎么做这份工作。黄油游说集团感到植物黄油构成了威胁。他们不会袖手旁观，看着这个暴发户成为新的流行面包抹酱。大黄油集团必须反击。第二章：公众之敌。在19世纪80年代，乳业游说集团协助传播关于植物黄油迫在眉睫的威胁的谣言和暗讽。这场关于植物黄油的虚假信息宣传的开始
and where it came from and what went into it. So there was this kind of lured campaign against margarine. Tell me about this disinformation campaign. Like, what were the crazy rumors going around about margarine? They mostly painted a picture of it being the slag from butcher shops. Here's Natalie Cook from McGill University in Montreal. She's a food historian. A food historian who sometimes talks about butter, that's right, third butter historian.
以及它来自哪里，里面有什么。所以针对植物黄油有一场这种诱导性的宣传。跟我讲讲这场虚假信息宣传。比如，当时流传着关于植物黄油的什么疯狂谣言？它们主要把它描绘成肉店里的下脚料。这是来自蒙特利尔麦吉尔大学的娜塔莉·库克（Natalie Cook）。她是一位食物历史学家。一位偶尔谈论黄油的食物历史学家，没错，第三位黄油历史学家。
Anyway, the disinformation campaign went to some wild extremes. There were editorial cartoons that made margarine sound awful. Some of the earlier cartoons show these wonderful vats of oil with things being thrown into them, you know, shoes, animals, you know, the odd mouse. The sort of disgusting things that one wouldn't want to see so that it could all be boiled down into margaring. And so that was the argument, what is in this rather ugly mess of fat?
无论如何，虚假信息宣传走向了一些疯狂的极端。有一些社论漫画让植物黄油听起来很可怕。早期的一些漫画展示了这些奇妙的油桶，里面被扔进了一些东西，你知道的，鞋子、动物，你知道的，偶尔还有老鼠。诸如此类令人作呕的东西，人们不会想看到它们被煮成植物黄油。所以当时的争论是，这个相当丑陋的脂肪烂摊子里究竟有什么？
The campaign wasn't limited to rumors about the content of Marjorin. The dairy lobby also promoted stories about fraud, unethical shopkeepers who tricked their customers by pretending that Marjorin was butter. The butter and cheese exchange actually sent out an inspector to test suspicious products. This inspector goes into the store and he finds this product being sold for the same price as butter, but it's not butter and they take it to a chemist and it's shown to be not butter. So there's a lot of that going on. It's unclear how much Butterfrog was actually happening,
这场宣传并不局限于关于植物黄油成分的谣言。乳业游说集团还宣传了关于欺诈的故事，即不道德的店主通过伪装植物黄油是黄油来欺骗他们的顾客。黄油和奶酪交易所实际上派出了一名检查员来检测可疑产品。这个检查员走进商店，发现这个产品以和黄油相同的价格出售，但它不是黄油，他们把它带给化学家，结果证明它不是黄油。所以有很多这样的情况。目前还不清楚到底发生了多少黄油欺诈，
but the stories were effective. And soon politicians were passing laws across America to stop the pernicious spread of Marjorin. Butterfraud became a crime in New York State and Maryland, punishable by 30 days in prison. The Marjorin War was getting intense. In 1884, New York State even tried to pass a full ban on Marjorin, but an appeal squirt struck that down because, you know, come on, it on Marjorin, but an appeal squirt struck that down because
但这些故事很有效。很快，政客们就在全美通过法律来阻止植物黄油的恶性蔓延。黄油欺诈在纽约州和马里兰州成为了一种犯罪，可处以30天监禁。植物黄油战争变得非常激烈。1884年，纽约州甚至试图通过一项对植物黄油的全面禁令，但上诉法院将其推翻了，因为，你知道的，拜托，那是植物黄油，但上诉法院将其推翻了，因为
he'd come on, it's Marjorin. Other states tried banning it too with mixed success, so pro-butter politicians had an idea. If they couldn't ban Marjorin, maybe they could make it so unpleasant, no one would want to eat it. Across the country, states passed laws that required Margin to be died so it didn't look like butter. Some states toyed with red or even black Margin, but one color became the most prominent.
拜托，那是植物黄油。其他州也试图禁止它，但成效不一，所以支持黄油的政客们有了一个主意。如果他们无法禁止植物黄油，也许他们可以把它搞得那么令人不快，以至于没人想吃它。全国各地的州都通过了法律，要求将植物黄油染色，这样它看起来就不像黄油了。一些州尝试了红色甚至黑色的植物黄油，但有一种颜色最为突出。
Vermont in 1884, New Hampshire and West Virginia in 1891, all required that it be colored pink, so imagine spreading pink margarine on your red. It took about something very unappetizing at your morning breakfast. required that it be colored pink. So imagine spreading pink margarine on your bread. It took about something very unappetizing at your morning breakfast. Laws about the color of Margarine were on the books until the 1950s and 60s in many states. And they lingered in places like Quebec
佛蒙特州在1884年，新罕布什尔州和西弗吉尼亚州在1891年，都要求将其染成粉红色，所以想象一下在你的面包上抹上粉红色的植物黄油。这让你的早饭变得非常倒胃口。要求将其染成粉红色。所以想象一下在你的面包上抹上粉红色的植物黄油。这让你的早饭变得非常倒胃口。关于植物黄油颜色的法律在许多州一直持续到20世纪50年代和60年代。并且它们在魁北克等地一直延续到
into the early 2000s when I spread that white gray margarine on my toast. Margarine color laws were completely hypocritical because food dye is used in butter all the time. Butter actually changes color, a different season of the year. So, depending on a cow's diet, obviously butter can look quite different. The margarine color laws served as a de facto ban in a lot of states. It just didn't make sense for manufacturers to die some of their margin pink and then truck it across state lines and then sell it to these customers who already thought because of propaganda that margin was made of, I
2000年代初，当时我在吐司上涂抹那种灰白色的植物黄油。植物黄油颜色法完全是虚伪的，因为食品染料一直被用在黄油中。黄油的颜色其实会随着一年中不同的季节而改变。所以，根据奶牛的饮食，很明显黄油看起来可以完全不同。植物黄油颜色法在许多州实际上起到了事实上的禁令的作用。制造商把他们的一些植物黄油染成粉红色，然后用卡车将其运过州界，再卖给这些由于宣传已经认为植物黄油是由，我
don't know, pigeon beaks or something. Margin became an embarrassing thing to eat. It was definitely for the working class and so that's why it was such a stigma to have some awfully colored food, you know, on your plate it just meant, oh, you're poor, you're working class. I think they were really trying to keep it out of the middle, the so-called middle class, you know, like the poor people got what they got. I think they were really trying to keep it from going any further. Finally, Congress got involved. They tried to kill Marjorin once and for all.
不知道，鸽子嘴之类的东西制成的人，对制造商来说根本没有意义。植物黄油成了一种吃起来很尴尬的东西。它绝对是为工人阶级准备的，所以这就是为什么盘子里有这种颜色可怕的食物会带有如此大的污名，这只意味着，哦，你很穷，你是工人阶级。我认为他们真的是想把它挡在中间阶层之外，也就是所谓的中间阶级，你知道的，穷人得到了他们应得的东西。我认为他们真的是想阻止它走得更远。最终，国会介入了。他们试图彻底消灭植物黄油。
In 1886, a bill was introduced that would require a 10 cent tax on every pound of Marjorin's soul. A tax so big, it would definitely kill the Marjorin industry. Supporters of the bill pulled out all the rhetorical stops and put it in more realistic terms, saying, Marjorin was unnatural in industrial, while Butter was pure and beautiful. Here's a quote from Housemember David Henderson of Iowa.
1886年，一项法案被提出，要求对售出的每一磅植物黄油征收10美分的税。这是一项如此巨额的税，它绝对会扼杀植物黄油产业。该法案的支持者们用尽了所有的修辞手段，并以更现实的说法来表达，称植物黄油是不自然的工业制品，而黄油是纯洁而美丽的。以下是来自爱荷华州的众议院议员大卫·亨德森（David Henderson）的一段话。
You will find Butter in the Bible, from Genesis to Revelations. You will hardly find a book in the Bible that does not speak of Butter. The article came to use before profane history was written. Milk and butter have been the food of man from time immemorial, and you do not mean medical certificates or the resolutions of boards of trade to tell you that butter is a whole sum article of food. He went on like this for quite some time. Herodicist speaks of butter, 460 years before the Christian era. And then after talking about how butter was an ancient Rome and the land of
你会在《圣经》中找到黄油，从《创世记》到《启示录》。你很难在《圣经》中找到一本不谈论黄油的书。这篇文章在世俗历史被书写之前就已经投入使用了。自古以来，牛奶和黄油就是人类的食物，你不需要医疗证明或贸易委员会的决议来告诉你黄油是一种健康的食品。他这样滔滔不绝地讲了相当长的一段时间。希罗多德在基督教纪元前460年就谈到了黄油。接着在谈到黄油如何在古罗马、流淌着
milken honey and all this other stuff, he finally got around to margarine. Now, let me give you the first record I find of Oliomargerin. In the fourth act of a play of Macbeth, where there was a little cotillion of witches, I find Oliomargerin completely described. If you haven't read Macbeth in a while, it's the double, double, toil, and trouble Fireburn in Cauldron bubble speech. Just to be clear, I have newt and Toa Frog is not what Marjorin is made from, but I think you get his point.
奶与蜜之乡以及所有这些其他事情之后，他终于谈到了植物黄油。现在，让我告诉你我找到的关于“油质人造黄油”的第一条记录。在《麦克白》一剧的第四幕中，有一场由女巫组成的小型舞会，我找到了对油质人造黄油的完整描述。如果你有一段时间没读过《麦克白》了，那就是“双倍，双倍，辛劳和麻烦，火烧大锅水泡翻滚”的台词。为了澄清起见，我没有把蝾螈和青蛙当作植物黄油的原料，但我想你明白他的意思了。
There was a lot of talk like this. Butter is pastoral and ancient, and Marjorin is basically witchcraft. It didn't matter that Marjorin was just a spread you put on toast. It had come to represent so much more. Ultimately, the Marjorin act passed, but the tax was reduced to two cents. And the industry survived. Marjorin was hanging on by a toe,
有许多这样的话题。黄油是田园诗般的、古老的，而植物黄油基本上是巫术。植物黄油只是一种抹在吐司上的酱料，这并不重要。它已经代表了更多。最终，植物黄油法案通过了，但税收被减到了两美分。这个行业生存了下来。植物黄油命悬一线，
but in the 20th century, it came roaring back. Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, Shrink, 3. A War Hero and a Health Food In the early 20th century, Marjorn became more commonplace. A new process called hydrogenation made it possible to use vegetable oils in Marjorn instead of beef and pork fat. Sure, Marjorn was still a processed mis-refood, but now it was a processed mis-refood that was made from vegetables. Marjorin also got a boost from the two war wars. First of all, there was a butter shortage during the wars, partly because men and boys
但在20世纪，它卷土重来。缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，缩小，第3章：战争英雄与健康食品。在20世纪初，植物黄油变得更加普遍。一种叫做氢化作用的新工艺使得在植物黄油中使用植物油而不是牛肉和猪肉脂肪成为可能。当然，植物黄油仍然是一种加工过的代用食品，但现在它是一种由蔬菜制成的加工过的代用食品。植物黄油也从两次世界大战中得到了提振。首先，战争期间出现了黄油短缺，部分原因是男孩子们
went off to fight the wars so those less of what worked for us on the dairy farms, but also because a lot of butter was shipped to the troops, they would have actual real butter. So Margarine could kind of fill the gap. Really, I mean, almost overnight, the battle against Margarine just went away. Americans were getting a taste for Margarine. And you know what?
去参军打仗了，所以乳牛场的人手变少了，但也因为大量的黄油被运往前线部队，他们可以吃到真正的黄油。所以植物黄油可以填补这个空白。真的，我的意思是，几乎在一夜之间，针对植物黄油的战斗就消失了。美国人开始品尝植物黄油。你知道吗？
They kind of liked it. Sales went up, and in the post-war era, Margarine producers spent money on luxuries like advertising and celebrity endorsements. Years ago, most people never dreamed of eating marjoram, but times have changed. That is the voice of Eleanor Roosevelt.
他们挺喜欢它的。销量上升了，在战后时代，植物黄油生产商把钱花在奢侈品上，比如广告和名人代言。多年前，大多数人从没想过吃植物黄油，但时代变了。那是埃莉诺·罗斯福（Eleanor Roosevelt）的声音。
Nowadays, you can get a marjoram like the new Good Luck, which really tastes delicious. That's what I've spread on my toast. Good night. I thoroughly enjoy it." For years, Marjorin sales climbed, and ads flooded the airwaves, telling consumers, Marjorin could do all the same stuff as butter at a fraction of the price. Some of the ads didn't even reference butter by name. Now Imperial combines the best of both table spread, the best qualities of margarine, easy spread ability, consistent quality, and the best qualities of nature's own spread. Natural taste, natural aroma. Political opposition to
如今，你可以买到像新好运牌（Good Luck）这样的植物黄油，它真的非常美味。这就是我涂在吐司上的。晚安。我非常享受它。”多年来，植物黄油的销量不断攀升，广告铺天盖地，告诉消费者，植物黄油可以像黄油一样做所有的事情，而价格只是其中的一小部分。有些广告甚至没有按名字提及黄油。现在，帝国牌结合了两种餐桌抹酱的最佳特质：植物黄油的最佳品质、易涂抹性、稳定的品质，以及大自然自己抹酱的最佳品质。自然的口味，自然的芳香。对
margarine slowly melted away and by 1967 all the American laws regulating margarine color had been repealed. By the 1970s, Americans were eating about 10 pounds of margarine per person every year, and as margarine became more widely adopted, it developed a new reputation. This spread used to be reviled as a mystery substance full of animal bits, but as diaculture changed, marjorin became a health food. On the heels of the war and rationing, you have this post-war
植物黄油的政治反对声慢慢消融，到1967年，美国所有规范植物黄油颜色的法律都被废除了。到了20世纪70年代，美国人每人每年大约吃10磅植物黄油，随着植物黄油被更广泛地采用，它建立了一种新的声誉。这种抹酱过去曾被痛斥为充满动物碎块的神秘物质，但随着饮食文化的改变，植物黄油成了健康食品。在战争和配给结束后，迎来了这个战后
period where the issue of heart disease became something of a crisis in this country because there were so many middle-aged executives dying of heart disease. After World War II, a consensus formed among food scientists that saturated fats were the root cause of American heart disease. Suddenly, butter was a big no-no, and margarine took over the dairy aisle.
时期，心脏病问题在这个国家成为了一种危机，因为有太多中年高管死于心脏病。第二次世界大战后，食品科学家们达成共识，认为饱和脂肪是美国人患心脏病的根本原因。突然之间，黄油成了大忌，植物黄油接管了乳制品货架。
It did eclipse butter in sales, and again, this was around the 70s to 80s, so they literally changed places on the graph. Yes, Margarine was riding high. Nothing could stop America's favorite butter substitutes. Chapter 4. Something stops Margarine. While nutritionists were singling out animal fats, they weren't paying attention to the problems with vegetable oil. The hydrogenation process created a new kind of fat, called trans fat. By the early 2000s, pretty much everybody knew trans fats were bad for you. I think you remember the giant panic about this.
它的销量确实超过了黄油，同样，这大约在70年代到80年代，所以它们在图表上的位置实际上发生了对调。是的，植物黄油风头正劲。没有什么能阻止美国人最喜欢的黄油替代品。第4章：有什么东西阻止了植物黄油。虽然营养学家将动物脂肪挑出来批判，但他们却没有注意到植物油存在的问题。氢化过程产生了一种叫做反式脂肪的新型脂肪。到2000年代初，几乎每个人都知道反式脂肪对你不利。我想你还记得关于这方面的巨大恐慌。
More than that big announcement from the FDA requiring companies to phase out all trans fats from our food, saying this could save up to 7,000 lives a year. With the FDA's announcement about trans fat, you probably wonder what are trans fats doing in our food in the first place. It's all about it. Now we now know those trans fats probably worse
更不用说美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）的那项重大公告，要求各大公司逐步淘汰我们食品中的所有反式脂肪，称这每年可以拯救多达7,000人的生命。随着FDA关于反式脂肪的公告，你可能会想，反式脂肪最初到底在我们的食品里做什么？这全都是关于它的。现在我们知道这些反式脂肪可能比
than the fully saturated fats all along, that the margarine was probably worse than the fully saturated fats all along. That the margarine was probably worse than the butter all along, which is why corn. Margarine producers largely got rid of hydrogenated oil, but it was too late. Today Americans eat a lot more butter than margarine. Landau Lakes, the biggest butter producer in America, says butter sales were up 20% last year, because of the boom in pandemic baking. My grandmother still has margaring in her fridge. Only now, it's yellow.
一直以来的完全饱和脂肪还要糟糕，植物黄油可能一直比完全饱和脂肪还要糟糕，植物黄油可能一直比黄油还要糟糕，这就是为什么玉米。植物黄油生产商在很大程度上摆脱了氢化油，但为时已晚。如今，美国人吃的黄油比植物黄油多得多。兰多湖（Land O'Lakes），美国最大的黄油生产商，表示由于疫情期间烘焙热潮的兴起，去年的黄油销量增长了20%。我祖母的冰箱里仍然有植物黄油。只是现在，它是黄油色的。
In 2008, over 130 years after the first margaring laws, Quebec finally allowed yellow margaring. But it wasn't because of some big public outcry. It's because nobody cared anymore. It's hard to imagine there was a time when people tried to outlaw Marjorin or share disinformation about it. But we shouldn't count out Marjorin. Recently, it's become tied to another major food trend.
2008年，在第一部植物黄油法案出台130多年后，魁北克终于允许了黄色植物黄油。但这不是因为什么巨大的公众抗议。是因为已经没有人再在乎了。很难想象曾几何时，人们试图取缔植物黄油或传播关于它的虚假信息。但我们不应该低估植物黄油。最近，它与另一个重大食品趋势联系在一起。
As people cut animal products from their diet, there's been a rise in plant-based butters. These butters are marketed with pastoral names like Earth Balance. But if you look at the list of ingredients, these so-called butters look a whole lot like Marjoram. The only difference is they're vegan. I see this plant-based revival
随着人们从饮食中剔除动物产品，植物性黄油有所增加。这些黄油以像“地球平衡”（Earth Balance）这样的田园名称进行营销。但如果你看一下配料表，这些所谓的黄油看起来很像植物黄油。唯一的区别是它们是纯素的。我把这种植物性复兴
as the latest evolution for Marjoram. A way of lashing itself onto another cycle in our food culture. Marjoram keeps writing this big pendulum of taste of what we think is good for us or bad for us. And along the way, it's been a miracle of science, than a villain, then a war hero, and a health food. But above all, it's been a survivor.
视为植物黄油的最新演变。这是它将自己捆绑到我们饮食文化中另一个周期的一种方式。植物黄油不断书写着口味的巨大钟摆，关于我们认为对我们有益还是有害的看法。在这条道路上，它曾是科学的奇迹，然后是恶棍，然后是战争英雄，以及健康食品。但最重要的是，它是一个幸存者。
More Marjorin mysteries after this. So I'm back with Chris Baroube and Chris, I hear you have a couple more Marjorine, Marjorine Alia stories for us. Indeed I do Roman. I have so much Marjorine knowledge that I need to spread across our listenership. Okay. Despite that wordplay, you can go ahead. Thank you. So, there are so many twists and turns in the story that we weren't able to get to.
更多植物黄油的谜团，广告之后揭晓。所以我回到了克里斯·巴鲁贝身边，克里斯，我听说你还有几个关于植物黄油的故事要讲给我们听。我确实有，罗曼。我有如此多的植物黄油知识，我需要向我们的听众普及。好吧。尽管有这种双关语，你还是可以继续。谢谢。所以，这个故事中有太多的曲折，我们之前没能讲到。
And one example is, did you know Roman in New Zealand until 1974, you needed a note from a doctor to get Marjorin? That's how afraid people were if it's health effects. And here's the big one I'm really excited to talk about. So remember how we've been talking about the pink Marjorin laws and those getting repealed? And those were laws were essentially that they were making Marjorin manufacturers add artificial dyes to make them slightly less palatable so they didn't compete with butter.
其中一个例子是，罗曼，你知道在纽西兰直到1974年，你需要医生的处方才能买到植物黄油吗？人们对它的健康影响是多么害怕。这里有一个我真的很兴奋想谈论的大事件。所以还记得我们一直在谈论的粉红色植物黄油法律以及那些被废除的法律吗？这些法律本质上是迫使植物黄油制造商添加人工染料，使其稍微不那么可口，这样它们就不会与黄油竞争。
That's it. Yeah. Exactly right. And actually, the reason those were repealed is because of the Supreme Court. So in 1998, the Supreme Court overruled a law in New Hampshire requiring Marjorine to be pink. And they said, quote, the state has no power to provide that Marjorine shall be colored or rather discolored by adding a foreign substance to it
就是这样。是的。完全正确。事实上，这些法律被废除的原因是因为最高法院。所以在1998年，最高法院推翻了新罕布什尔州要求植物黄油必须是粉红色的法律。他们说，引述：“州无权规定植物黄油应当通过向其中添加外来物质来着色，或者说使其变色。”
So that struck down laws saying Marjorin had to be pink or red or black But there were still laws on the books in lots of states saying Marjorin could not be yellow So it's the kind of law we talked about with Quebec that was still in effect until the early 2000s So it so the Marjorin had to be it's kind of like it couldn't be died to make it unpalatable, but it also couldn't be died in some places to make it more palatable, more butter like it. It was just the kind of pearly white, you know, substance that you encountered when you were a kid.
所以这推翻了那些规定植物黄油必须是粉红色、红色或黑色的法律。但许多州的法案中仍然保留着这样的法律，规定植物黄油不能是黄色。所以这就是我们谈论的魁北克的法律，它一直有效到2000年代初。所以，植物黄油必须是——这有点像它不能被染成令人倒胃口的样子，但它在某些地方也不能被染得更有食欲、更像黄油。它只是那种当你还是个孩子时遇到的珠光白色的物质。
That's right. And actually Roman, the last holdout in the United States to have a law like this was Wisconsin, who had a law like this was Wisconsin who had a law like this on the books until 1967. That makes sense. They're like the dairy state. So they, you know, they could imagine that they were like extra protective of their home industry.
没错。事实上，罗曼，美国最后一个拥有这种法律的州是威斯康星州，它有这样一条法律在册，一直持续到1967年。这说得通。他们就像是乳业之州。所以他们，你知道的，你可以想象他们对本地产业格外具有保护意识。
So yes, to stereotype Wisconsin for a second, yes, this is why this happened. So there were these laws on the books saying you couldn't put yellow food dye in Marjorin. And actually the federal Marjorin act was amended to add this like big tax to any Marjorin that used yellow food dye. So producers try to figure out ways around this. So the people who make Marjorin around World War One started using oils that gave Marjorin kind of a natural yellow color. So they weren't dying at yellow. It was just part of the production process. So they used coconut oil that gave Marjorin kind of a natural yellow color. So they weren't dying at yellow. It was just part of the production process.
所以是的，为了对威斯康星州进行一点刻板印象化，是的，这就是为什么会这样。所以当时法律规定你不能在植物黄油中加入黄色食用色素。事实上，联邦植物黄油法案被修正，对任何使用黄色食用色素的植物黄油征收重税。因此，制造商试图寻找绕过这一限制的方法。所以在第一次世界大战前后，植物黄油的生产商开始使用能够赋予植物黄油一种天然黄色调的油。所以他们不是把它染成黄色。这只是生产过程的一部分。所以他们使用椰子油，赋予了植物黄油一种天然的黄色调。所以他们不是把它染成黄色。这只是生产过程的一部分。
So they used coconut oil. They gave it kind of a yellowish hue. And then politicians were like, okay, we see what you're doing here. We don't like this. So then they just banned all yellow margarines, whether it was like a natural color or a food dye. They either banded or they taxed it. And the marjorin producers had to figure out another way around it.
所以他们使用椰子油。它赋予了它一种微黄的色调。然后政客们就觉得，好吧，我们看到你们在搞什么鬼了。我们不喜欢这样。于是他们索性禁止了所有的黄色植物黄油，无论是天然颜色还是食用色素。他们要么禁止它，要么对它征税。而植物黄油的生产商不得不寻找另一种绕过它的方法。
So they started sending out the white tubs of Marjoram with little yellow die packs. So you could mix in the yellow color at home into your Marjoram. So it's like a home project. Exactly. It's hilarious. It's like this family activity. You could all do together where you? Kind of stirring it in. And it's funny, there was actually in the 50s in Canada, there was this series of ads
所以他们开始分发白色的植物黄油桶，里面附带小包的黄色染料。这样你就可以在家把黄色混入你的植物黄油中。所以这就像是一个家庭手工作业。完全正确。这太搞笑了。这就像是一项全家人可以一起做的家庭活动，你们？一边搅拌一边做。有趣的是，在50年代的加拿大，曾有过一系列广告
starring this fictional homemaker named Brenda York, who showed people how to do this, like how to do the mixing. So here's Natalie Cook. She is one of our food historians. She's suggesting that, A, it's an economic spread for your bread, it's tasty. She's also having to make a rather difficult argument. She's having to show us in real time that it's a very pleasant activity to be massaging the nipple of dye into a rather horrible mess of margarine, and so she's wearing a white lab coat and smiling all the time as she is demonstrating that this can be done pleasantly, efficiently, quickly. Now, I know how that sounds. It doesn't sound pleasant, efficient, or quick.
由一个虚构的家庭主妇布伦达·约克（Brenda York）主演，她向人们展示了如何做到这一点，比如如何进行混合。这是娜塔莉·库克。她是我们的食物历史学家之一。她暗示，第一，这是你抹面包的一种经济实惠的酱料，而且很美味。她还不得不提出一个相当困难的论点。她必须向我们实时展示，将一滴染料揉进一堆相当可怕的植物黄油中是一项非常愉快的活动，所以她穿着一件白大褂，在演示这项工作可以愉快、高效、迅速地完成时一直微笑着。现在，我知道这听起来怎么样。它听起来一点也不愉快、高效或迅速。
It's awful. It does't sound pleasant, efficient or quick. It's awful. It does not sound fun at all. It really doesn't. And during the process of reporting this, I actually found somebody who remembers using those dipaxes, who is around when they were still for sale. And one of the experts I spoke to for this story
这太糟糕了。这听起来一点也不愉快、高效或迅速。这太糟糕了。听起来一点也不好玩。真的不好玩。在报道这个过程时，我实际上找到了一位还记得使用过那些染料包的人，他是在这些产品仍在销售的时候过来的。我在这个故事中采访的其中一位专家
is Mary Nestle. She's a food historian. She's written quite a few books, Professor Maritissid NYU. And when I brought this up is Mary Nestle. She's a food historian. She's written quite a few books, Professor Maritissette NYU, and when I brought this up with Mary, and here's how she described the process of mixing the dye into the margaret. Well, you got this white block of fat,
是玛丽·内斯利（Marion Nestle）。她是一位食物历史学家。她写过不少书，是纽约大学的荣誉退休教授。当我向玛丽提起这件事时——她是食物历史学家，写过不少书，是纽约大学的荣誉退休教授——当我向玛丽提起这件事时，她是这样描述把染料混合到植物黄油中的过程的。嗯，你有一大块白色的脂肪，
and then you got a packet of food dye, and with great effort, you mix them together. So it would look like butter. But people didn't want to eat it. It was awful looking. She told me it came out very strappy. So even if you tried to mix it together, it just never totally mixed. You could totally imagine it not working well at all. And you also can really tell that she seems to have a pretty strong disdain for for Marjorin and this process. Yeah, I would say her distaste for Marjorin has carried over from childhood. Actually,
然后你有一包食用色素，你费了九牛二虎之力把它们混在一起。这样它看起来就像黄油了。但人们并不想吃它。它看起来很糟糕。她告诉我它出来时非常条纹状。所以即使你试图把它混在一起，它也永远无法完全混合。你完全可以想象它根本不起作用。而且你也能看出她对植物黄油和这个过程有着相当强烈的厌恶。是的，可以说她对植物黄油的厌恶从童年一直延续到了现在。事实上，
this is this is one of the first things that she said to me during the interview. My response to hearing that you were interested in Marjorin was does anybody still eat it? So yeah, obviously, that's a bit of an exaggeration as we were talking about. There are people for religious reasons or dietary reasons or habit who still love Margarine. And the new big thing is these plant-based butters, which do have a lot of similarities to Margarine.
这是她在采访中对我说第一句话之一。我对听说你对植物黄油感兴趣的回应是“还有人吃这东西吗？”所以是的，很明显，正如我们所谈到的，这有点夸张。有些人出于宗教原因、饮食原因或习惯，仍然喜欢植物黄油。而现在的新大趋势是这些植物性黄油，它们确实与植物黄油有很多相似之处。
So, you know, Margarine, it's a survivor, it's hanging in there. It is such a fascinating story. So thank you so much for bringing to us and this little extra bit just to gross us out at the very end. It's just want to give everyone a lovely image to go home with from our Marjoram story. Thanks a lot, Roman.
所以，你知道，植物黄油，它是个幸存者，它还在坚持。这是一个非常迷人的故事。非常感谢你把它带给我们，还有最后这个稍微有点恶心到我们的额外小片段。只是想在我们的植物黄油故事结束时给每个人留下一个美好的画面。非常感谢，罗曼。
Thanks, Chris. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUT [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO 99% of visible was produced this week by Chris Baroupe and edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Darah Hirsch, music by our director of Sound Swan Rihau. Brandon Hackett was the voice of David Henderson. Delaney Hall as the executive producer, Kurt Kohlstei is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Lashemadon, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Citroën Series XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
谢谢你，克里斯。[♪ 片尾音乐播放] 本周的“99%隐形”由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑，达拉·赫施（Darah Hirsch）负责混音和技术制作，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里豪（Swan Real）提供。布兰登·哈克特（Brandon Hackett）为大卫·亨德森配音。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔施泰因（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括拉什马·多恩（Lashma Don）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、索菲娅·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是天狼星XM播客（SiriusXM Podcast）家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼往北六个街区。
And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-P.I.O.R.K. on Instagram and write it too. You can find links to other estituer shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. You're listening to a podcast.
这里是美丽的高地，加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于它的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，在Instagram上@99PI.ORG关注该节目并进行评论。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜爱的其他埃斯特机构节目的链接，以及99PI的每一期往期节目。你正在收听一个播客。
Yeah, you're listening Stitcher. You're listening to a podcast. Stitcher. Yeah, you're listening to a podcast. Stitcher. You're listening to a Stitcher. Yeah, you're listening to PondCast. Stitcher. You're listening to a Stitcher podcast. Serious exam. Now what I said. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，你在收听Stitcher。你正在收听一个播客。Stitcher。是的，你正在收听一个播客。Stitcher。你正在收听一个Stitcher播客。是的，你在收听池塘播客。Stitcher。你正在收听一个Stitcher播客。天狼星XM。我现在说的是这个。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。